being better with money all right
i would divide
being better with money into
two different categories
and keeping in mind that for me a good
investment is one that increases your
quality of life why otherwise would you
invest
so if you say
are invested in crypto and the
percentage gains are very attractive but
you're a complete
crackhead compulsively checking the
charts every 15 minutes is that a good
investment
well that's a question for you to sit
with but if it
progressively worsens your quality of
life or consistently creates more
anxiety than you had beforehand
is the marginal utility of the dollars
you are gaining
as reflected in that percentage
enough to offset that with some type of
lump sum payment of happiness or
improved quality of life at the end
maybe not but this is something worth
considering coming back to what i was
saying though i tend to think of money
as
getting rich staying rich so there are
different tools in the toolkit for
getting rich different tools than in the
staying rich category
and
i would say if you're looking at beating
the market so alpha i i don't do that
in hands-off styles of investing
i i have that very much on one side of
my barbell so i personally
partially by choice and partially by
fate have ended up with a very
barbell
looking
asset distribution
and if you were to look at what i have
you're going to have highly volatile
what most people consider highly risky
class of investments namely startups and
cryptocurrency
that's going to be
more than 50 percent of my total assets
and then you have real estate and cash
or cash cash-like equivalents and that's
pretty much it so on opposite ends of
the spectrum and we could debate whether
or not
real estate is risky we could debate
the benefits of cash if
you also have to contend with inflation
but let's just keep it simple for the
sake of this this discussion and say
that you have
uh highly volatile
what most people would consider high
risk high reward categories like
privately held startups and
cryptocurrency on one end of the barbell
which is where i create
my alpha and then you have real estate
cash cash like equivalence and
things like for instance muni bonds and
so on where you would then
preserve that alpha okay so you create
alpha take it off the table and then
preserve alpha now
forget about the question of converting
crypto into fiat or keeping it in crypto
let's just keep it simple
so that is
currently what my say asset allocation
would look like that is
very very likely to change over time and
i should address a couple of questions
that likely come to mind one would be
why on earth do you have more than 50
percent of your net worth in startups
and crypto
and it is not
because i had a hundred units of assets
and decided
to put 50 plus percent of those units
into crypto and startups that would be
complete insanity i think for almost
anyone it's because i started off with a
very reasonable allocation some of you
might remember that many years ago 2008
or so i created for myself a real world
mba rather than
going to a stanford gsb or one of these
graduate school programs of business i
decided to take the same amount of money
over two years at that point it was 60
000 a year for two years
and invest that into
the tim ferriss fund in quotation marks
to try my hand at startup investing in
the very beginning piggybacking and
co-investing with people who knew what
they were doing
and i assumed the network built the
skills developed the knowledge acquired
over that two year period of time
would
benefit me more than the 120 000
which i assumed i would lose the
assumption was much like tuition that
would be a sunk cost
and that then set me on this accidental
career of being an early stage tech
angel investor and advisor and that tiny
sliver
of my total pie chart at that time
due to
lucky slash good investments and
company selection
has swollen to a gigantic percentage of
the total pie chart with companies like
uber facebook twitter alibaba and so on
uh crypto very similarly uh has has not
necessarily risen as it would have had i
gone in early with something like
ethereum
but has nonetheless doubled and so on
over time more than doubled
so
if you look at my cost basis it was a
very rational well semi-rational
decision at the at the time to allocate
what i allocated but due to growth
they now represent a very very large
percentage of my total holdings and the
crypto can be freely traded the startups
are locked up all right so i am unable
to decrease my positions and balance
those
for the most part
and that is why my portfolio looks the
way it does i would not recommend my
asset allocation
to really anyone
now this comes back to
uh the question of
financial freedom getting better with
money
if we're looking at the
the getting rich part the building
wealth for a less crass way to put it
building wealth preserving wealth sounds
a lot fancier much more uh
rockefeller than nouveau riche so let's
stick with that all right building
wealth preserving wealth
the way that i have
if we're assuming there's some
aspect of skill involved and that i'm
not just uh lucky lucky lucky lucky
which could be the case right if you
have a thousand orangutans flip coins
long enough as warren buffett would say
oh actually warren buffett wouldn't say
this the efficient market market
theorist folks would say this you know a
thousand monkeys flipping coins
eventually you're going to find one or
two monkeys who flip you know 50 heads
in a row and then end up writing books
about how to flip coins and so on so
maybe i'm that monkey but
if we assume there's some element of
skill the way that i've thought about it
is number one
capping downside
first versus evaluating upside and
looking at the minimal downside and this
is borrowed from a lot of folks
including
some
famous names you might recognize warren
buffett for instance uh who's a would be
considered i think by most a value
investor or the charlie munger has
certainly informed their
their later investment styles paul tudor
jones
of hedge fund fame
and this is actually a
quote that i took from
tony robbins book unshakable
which is which is very good or money
master the game also very very good is
this truly the hard trade this is from
paul tudor jones paraphrasing is this
truly the hard trade question mark
meaning something others can't easily
replicate does this really have
asymmetric risk reward
is it a five to one or a three to one
that means for every dollar he is
risking is there the potential or
expectation of a three or five dollar
roi
what's the entry point what are your
stops these are all really really
good
questions and
the downside risk capping the downside
risk is also something that for instance
richard branson does when he started
virgin atlantic negotiating a lease with
boeing so that he could return the plane
or planes if it didn't work out so even
these people who are viewed as
inveterate risk takers people who throw
caution to the wind are in fact
determining how to limit their downside
right up front and looking for
asymmetric risks so in the startup world
that check the box you can put in 25k
max you know your maximum that you can
lose because you're not using leverage
or anything else 25k is the maximum you
can lose and yet there is the potential
if you
uh
focus on
an unfair advantage and we'll come back
to that that you could have a hundred
two thousand x return and
the startup world much like
publishing
book publishing music these are hits
driven businesses
and you are betting on companies or
books or musicians or albums that you
hope will return the fund
they will return all of the other
losses that you will incur
with your other bets
and
i do very well with those types of
decisions they are binary they are not
day trading they're certainly not
considering buying or selling on a
regular basis uh
at which point you become very
susceptible to mr market if you want to
look
up warren buffett mr market
that is who i am in the public markets
so i do not play much with
publicly traded equities for instance
even though that might be part of my
portfolio later
instead i like to do a ton of research
upfront make a binary decision
am i am i out and then i'm stuck and
that being stuck is actually a benefit
it is a constraint that works for me
in this case because i can't make cell
decisions at the wrong time it is out of
my hands
that does not suit everyone's intestinal
fortitude it just happens to suit my
weird psychology uh the unfair advantage
i mentioned i would come back to
is really only playing with a stacked
deck
so i
do not
make investments in startups where i
cannot materially impact directly the
value of that company or from the
selection standpoint when i have
unless i have
a significant informational advantage
and when i lived in silicon valley i was
there for 17 years i lived in the middle
of the switchbox and i made every effort
to ensure that i was in the
hub of information flow so i knew about
things
weeks months in some cases years in
advance
and that enabled me to make better
decisions as to where i should allocate
the tim ferriss fund in the first two
years certainly which worked out very
very well all right so this is a long
answer but for financial freedom uh
first understanding how to get out of
debt or how to manage debt
i use very very little debt in my life
some people are very comfortable with
that i am not
and being better with money is in part
not being afraid of money
and also
learning how to take
small steps
and moderate actions with limited
downside rather than being paralyzed by
any insecurities or fears you might have
about money so a book that i think
holistically can help with that is how
to stop worrying and start living by
dale carnegie has nothing directly to do
with money but it does have everything
to do with how you might interact
with money
the last thing i would say is coming
back again to financial freedom
is
to correct a misconception about
the spectrum between full-time employed
and entrepreneur
there is the erroneous belief the false
dichotomy that these things exist
completely separately in other words
that you you're either
a nine to fiver or work for someone else
or
you quit that job and
chase your dreams and your full-time
entrepreneur
i don't
recommend in most cases that you make
that black and white leap in fact it
makes much more sense
to moonlight to side gig
on say the weekends or saturdays for a
period of time so that you can
both assess and evaluate your ideas for
a company
but also assess and evaluate your own
abilities as an entrepreneur to for
instance structure time that is
otherwise unstructured to set your own
rules and policies instead of having
them set by someone else or some type of
company environment and not everyone is
suited to the uncertainty that you face
as an entrepreneur on an ongoing basis
and there's nothing wrong with that
it's it comes down to accurately
assessing your strengths and weaknesses
which certainly applies to investment
and guess what it's all investment
investment of money time energy
attention these are all investment
decisions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you